so we're starting to wind down 2019 and
because of our upcoming show vacation we
really only have a few new shows planned
for the year and one of the things that
has been a major downfall in 2019 really
has been YouTube YouTube hitting rock
bottom and I'm not talking about the
David Pakman show this is not one of
those stories there's a really
interesting article on reclaimed the net
which talks about how 2019 was really a
low point for YouTube it's been an
extremely demoralizing year for creators
and for the community and the article on
reclaim the net which were linking to in
the description for the YouTube video
for this story argues that there are no
signs that things are going to get
better in 2020 and this is true now many
of you know that 2019 has been a really
difficult year on YouTube for
independent news channels like ours as
creators but this is actually a much
bigger issue in the United States and
it's a much bigger issue than the David
Pakman show
particularly because we're about to
start an election year during election
years interest in politics skyrockets it
happens every election election years
historically are our biggest growth
years the stakes go way up there's much
more election and politically related
content being produced and published and
in 2016 and 2019 rather YouTube took a
significant step it officially changed
its algorithm in ways that are never
explained in detail to promote what they
call authoritative news and avoid
suggesting to people videos that are
what they have designated as borderline
content authoritative borderline you
have to understand the code that's being
used and of course the downside of this
which we can say I mean listen we can
say it's well-intentioned or not let's
assume for a moment that the downside of
trying to prevent promotion of white
supremacists and other hate content is
the unintended consequence of
independent shows like ours getting
crushed let's let's imagine that it was
completely an innocent thing that
happened as a side effect it has crushed
us right to the
tune of roughly two and a half million
views a month that we used to get from
YouTube's algorithm which we no longer
get instead CNN gets those views NBC Fox
News the usual suspects now I said let's
assume for a moment YouTube made these
changes to their algorithm for the right
reasons
not to hurt independent media but to
prevent recommendations of white
nationalist extremist hateful racist
content okay I think that in reality
YouTube is indifferent so what happens
to end independent shoes news shows like
ours they're not trying to hurt us but
they're indifferent if their algorithmic
changes take us down
along with the white nationalists and
the extremist stuff and one of the
reasons that I I see YouTube is
completely indifferent to independent
creators like us is that our channel is
pretty big on YouTube you know we're not
like those huge makeup youtubers and
games streamers with millions and
millions or tens of millions of
subscribers but with nearly 800,000
subscribers we are certainly in the top
1% of YouTube and and realistically
higher I can barely get ahold of a
YouTube person like I have a rep sort of
but they're never around and they said
I'm getting a different rep but I've
never told who that is and if I have any
issue I end up just filling out a form
you would imagine that if YouTube was
taking seriously its relationship with
independent news creators like us we are
in the top 1% of YouTube at least that
there would be some simpler mechanism
where we could actually talk to a person
I think that they're just indifferent
and has reclaimed the net rights
independent creators are as
underappreciated and unappreciated as
ever we're constantly being given new
rules that are rarely clear and almost
always opaque just in the last three
months I've been told about four to five
topics that are straight-up off-limits
for monetization I'll tell you one of
them is abortion I was told if you
mention abortion the content is not
monetizable period
sometimes things sneak by but that's the
rule I'm not even gonna mention the
other things at this point because
that's not really the focus here
copyright claims an endless issue
particularly in 2019 we've been getting
hit with dozens of copyright claims from
media outlets whose content were not
even
they are fraudulent copyright claims and
of course we then need to fight each one
suffer the financial consequences and
hope for the best
so 2019 for me is the year in which
YouTube stopped being the YouTube that
it used to be the YouTube that it was
created to be and YouTube in 2019 became
the online arm of a much more corporate
media platform now it's still huge for
us in terms of audience we're
approaching 800,000 subscribers the
channel got 13 million views in November
on track for 15 million views in
December which is the most views we've
ever had in a single month but something
has been irrevocably lost this year
which were sort of the last vestiges of
YouTube as a truly independent platform
for normal people to get their ideas and
videos out YouTube TV is part of it the
monetization crisis is part of it the
brand safety revolution is part of it
and it's sad in many many ways now what
will happen in 2020 I have no idea if
things sort of settle out like they are
now it won't be great
it'll still be a big important platform
for us to get our content out there our
live streams have successfully been
getting six seven even eight nine
thousand viewers at a time that's great
and we could be still well positioned
for the 2020 election if the clamp downs
continue if the crackdown scale up it's
anyone's guess and YouTube's 2020
election coverage could end up being
totally corporate which would really be
a perversion of the mission that
initially represented YouTube in the
early years my question to you has your
perception of YouTube changed over the
last year are you using YouTube
differently is your experience on
YouTube different now than it was 1 or 2
years ago let me know your thoughts
leave a reply if you're watching on
youtube or send me a tweet at D Pakman
privacy comm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy comm slash
Pakman privacy's a serve
I've been using for a while now I love
it it saves me a bunch of headaches it's
completely free and it's very quick to
set up and here's how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit-card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman